welcome and thanks for coming today
we're going to talk about running
node.js applications on Google cloud
platform we're going to take a look at
Google cloud build a few apps and learn
about using Google's advanced api's and
services with your applications but
before we dive in a little bit about
myself my name is Justin Beckwith and
I'm a product manager here at Google my
contact information is available here
so feel free to reach out at any time if
you have questions or feedback about
running node.js applications on Google
cloud platform as someone who spent
years as a web developer I found that
there's a lot to like about nodejs
many developers spend years writing
JavaScript for front-end web
applications one of the best parts of
node.js is that it's just JavaScript the
same skills you use to develop
applications in the browser can be used
to develop amazing applications in the
cloud as well it's easy to get ramped up
as the core of nodejs is very small many
of the libraries are going to use our
open source and have been developed by
the community last month there were over
4 billion packages downloaded through
NPM the node.js package manager this is
a sign of a community that's growing as
the node.js community continues to grow
it's becoming a great destination for
Enterprise focused web applications
nodejs offers a mature api and an LTS
release schedule that provides 18 months
of support over that same time Google
cloud platform has also grown and become
a great destination for web applications
and api's that need Google scale nodejs
is built on v8 the same javascript
engine that powers Google Chrome we have
years of experience tuning javascript
engines to provide incredible
performance in the browser and now we're
helping deliver that same incredible
performance in the cloud Google cloud
platform is also easy to use you can
bring your code and let us handle the
scale and the ops finally we offer a
variety of api's and services that allow
you to take advantage of Google's
incredible big data and machine learning
technology the same infrastructure and
API is that make it possible to run
services like Google search Gmail and
Google photos are
now at your fingertips helping you bring
your applications to life there are
three easy ways to run your applications
on Google Cloud App Engine is Google's
powerful easy-to-use platform as a
service
you bring your code and will handle the
rest App Engine will automatically scale
your application to handle spikes and
traffic provide no downtime upgrades and
make it easy to take advantage of our
advanced diagnostics tools in production
container engine is a hosted version of
kubernetes which brings Google's
container orchestration technology to
the cloud it's incredibly powerful for
applications that are already built on
top of docker and finally if you need
complete control and flexibility compute
engine offers traditional virtual
machines that you can manage and control
now that we know a little bit about
Google Cloud and nodejs let's build a
simple web application and deploy it to
App Engine you can get started using any
node.js framework you'd like but today
we're going to use Express a very common
module used for building web
applications and api's I'm going to
start by scaffolding a new web
application using Express we're going to
install our dependencies locally and
take a quick look at the app in action
this is a simple application now let's
get it up and running on App Engine to
get started you need to create a new
project in the Google cloud Developer
console I'm going to deploy to a project
I created earlier using the Google Cloud
SDK the G cloud preview app deploy
command will publish your code to Google
App Engine install any NPM dependencies
in your package JSON and start your app
under the hood we're creating cloud load
balancers virtual machines Auto scalars
managed instance groups
virtual networks everything you need to
build a great performing application
with a great SLA now that our
application has been deployed let's
check it out I'm going to run g-cloud
preview app browse to take a look at my
site in production and here you have it
a simple node.js application with
Express running on Google App Engine now
up to this point we've been using the
cloud SDK to work on our app let's take
a look at how we can use the Google
cloud developer console to help manage
it here we can see the App Engine
dashboard which provides a heads
view of our application performance
metrics there's a lot to explore with
App Engine but some of the most useful
features I want to talk about today are
under the versions tab in the developer
console App Engine makes it easy to
simultaneously run multiple versions of
your application this is useful in a few
situations first it's great for
performing no downtime deployments where
you want to test a new version of your
app before sending any users to the new
deployment you can see that I have a few
versions this app already deployed
here's the new version we just deployed
and the previous version we were running
this is a great feature if you need high
availability and no downtime upgrades in
our case we were routing a hundred
percent of our traffic to a new version
but what if you want to gradually rule
out your changes or what if you want to
perform a be testing and route different
users to distinct versions of your
application traffic splitting makes
enabling these kinds of setups simple as
we saw getting started with nodejs on
App Engine is really easy you can bring
your code and let us run it on Google's
infrastructure you can automatically
scale to millions of requests per second
and you don't need to have downtime
during your deployments now you may be
wondering what if I decide to use
container engine or I want to move my
application on-premise well I've got
great news the same docker image we use
to run your application on App Engine
can be used with container engine or
kubernetes or any other service that can
run docker containers our last
application was really simple it was
just a single web application with no
real back-end in reality our apps are
rarely this simple they're often more
complex because the problems we're
trying to solve for our customers are
also complex we need databases like
MongoDB Postgres or datastore to store
our content we need message queues for
connecting services we need advanced
services like the cloud vision API and
cloud ml to help us understand the world
around us we use advanced tools like
bigquery and dataflow to process
millions of records to gain valuable
insights on our products on Google cloud
platform you can combine all of these
Google products open source products
manage services bring your own use what
you want to build the experiences that
your
customers need when you're ready to take
advantage of Google's API s and services
you can use the G cloud NPM module this
npm module gives you access to over a
dozen google api s and services with
more on the way it works from with an
app engine kubernetes compute engine
even from applications that aren't
deployed to Google cloud platform in my
experience these are the services that
make Google magic containers the cloud
vision API bigquery machine learning we
can use these amazing technologies to
build applications that serve billions
of people all over the planet let's take
a look at how you can use these to get
started next we're going to take a look
at a fun little node.js application that
uses the G cloud NPM module this app
uses App Engine cloud storage the cloud
vision API and cloud pub/sub to analyze
images from the internet separate them
into pictures of dogs on the right and
cats on the left so now let's take a
look at how we can use these API s with
the G cloud NPM module to build this
kind of application to store our images
we're using Google Cloud Storage cloud
storage provides a scalable file store
great for images videos or other large
files that you want to keep out of your
database using the cloud storage API is
simple you can even use it to serve
static HTTP content next up is the cloud
vision API using this simple service
with five lines of code we can detect
common labels landmarks and even facial
expressions within an image almost
instantaneously finally we're using
cloud pub/sub to send messages between
the microservices that make up this
application cloud pub/sub provides low
latency durable messaging between
services or devices using these api's we
can take advantage of technology that's
been in development at Google for years
whether it's our machine learning
technology databases or big data tools
we have services that make building
amazing applications fast and scalable
of course sometimes you're going to run
into trouble we've all been in a
situation where code works great on our
machines but for one reason or another
starts giving us trouble in production
traditionally debugging these kinds of
problems has been very difficult but
with the stack draw
our Diagnostics tools we can dig deep
into performance and quality issues in
production let's take a look at
stackdriver trace in action in the
developer console I'm going to navigate
to the trace UI this will show an
overview of the overall latency for
request to my HTTP endpoints I'm going
to drill into the traces view which
provides a detailed breakdown of every
single outgoing HTTP and RPC call coming
from my app as you can see this last
request took around 10 seconds that's a
long time let's find out why I can see
that we're downloading a lot of images
to run through the cloud vision API you
can see every request we're making to
download images upload them to cloud
storage and analyze them with the cloud
vision API you can even click on a
request to get a drill down view that
shows the origin of the request in your
application source code this is a great
way to diagnose performance issues in
production but what if instead of a
performance issue you're facing a crash
stack driver debugger makes it easy to
analyze the state of your application in
production the debug console allows you
to set breakpoints in your production
code now this isn't a traditional
breakpoint when a request hits this code
path will analyze the state of your
application passively allowing you to
capture state without affecting
performance in production in review
stackdriver diagnostic tools make it
easy to diagnose issues in production we
looked at trace and debug but there are
a variety of other tools at your
disposal as well today we covered a lot
we looked at how App Engine is making it
easy to operate at Google scale we
looked at using Google's API s and
services to build amazing applications
we diagnose problems in production and
of course we talked about how Google
Cloud and nodejs
are a great match everything we looked
at today is open source the docker
images we use to build the node.js
runtime the G cloud NPM module the trace
and debug tools these are all open
source and available on github I'd like
to thank you again for coming and as I
mentioned please feel free to reach out
if you have any questions you can learn
more about building node.js applications
on Google cloud platform at cloud Google
com
/ no das